the series starts with viserys targaryen
played by an actor petty considine
sitting on the iron throne as the king
of westeros
his mount valerian the black dread king
viserys targaryen is chosen by the lords
of astros to succeed the old king
jaehaerys targaryen at the great council
at harrenhal
a warm kind and decent man viserys only
wishes to carry forward his
grandfather's legacy
but good men don't necessarily make for
great kings the king has a famous
brother about whom entire westeros tells
stories daemon targaryen the rogue
prince played by an actor matt smith
it's georgia martin's favorite targaryen
known as the prince of the city lord
flee bottom and the rogue prince he's
the most controversial man of his
lifetime an audacious rogue prince and
adventure who seems made of good and
evil in equal measure prince damon is
the most experienced warrior of his time
and wields the valyrian steel blade dark
sister a dragon rider whose dragon is
characters writings of westerosi
archmaester gives the best description
of daemon it reads over the centuries
house targaryen has produced both great
men and monsters
prince damon was both in his day there
was no man so admired so beloved and so
reviled in old westeros he was made of
light and darkness in equal parts
to some he was a hero to others the
blackest of villains king viserys also
has a daughter rhinera targaryen she
will be played by an actress emma darcy
princess rhaenyra targaryen cheered as
the realms delight is the first born
child of king viserys the first
targaryen
rhaenyra was king theirs the first only
living child by his first wife queen
emma of house serena at the age of eight
she was made her father's heir and grew
up expecting to become the first ruling
queen of esros
rainer is a dragon rider whose mount was
xyrex
rhaenyra and daemon are together despite
the fact that their niece and uncle
since the king's first wife died the
king married ellis and hightower she's
played by olivia cook with her he
finally gets male children the oldest of
which is aegon but still aegon's half
sister rhaenyra is older and even though
the king has male heirs rhaenyra remains
the official heir to the drown
at first young rhaenyra and alison got
along well but the rift grew between
them as soon as ellison produced her own
children for viserys the first and
clearly wanted them to succeed to the
throne instead of her alison bore with
aries the first four children
aegon ii and one eye there on the daring
and helina who became the sister wife of
aegon ii
the reason alice sent a miseries sweat
was alison's father otto hightower
played by ray siphons who had been kind
of the king in the last few years of the
long reign of king jaehaerys the first
targaryen
in 101ac otto brought the young alicent
to the royal court where she cared for
the aging king
jaehaerys eventually died in 103ac while
his scent was reading to him and was
succeeded by his grandson viserys the
first
the last but not least of the targaryens
from this time period we have princess
rhaenys known among the small folk as
the queen who never was she's the
granddaughter of jacarys the first
targaryen and the cousin of isaiah is
the first targaryen in daemon targaryen
as her father was the prince of
dragonstone and she was his first born
child many considered her as being next
in line for the iron throne but upon
quite a few unfortunate events such as
the death of her father she was passed
over the great council voted for her
cousin viserys to be the new king
rhaenys married legendary corliss of
house valerian and known as the sea
snake who will also play a major role in
the series and he's played by an actor
steve tusson while the first few
episodes will pretty much be a calm
before storm in which we'll get to know
all these characters the second half of
the first season will see the beginning
of the most devastating war westeros has
ever seen the dance of the dragons
it all starts when king viserys dies and
half of the kingdom sides with his
designated air rhaenyra while the other
half sides with queen elicent who pushes
the claim of her son aegon
we have the greens against the blacks
the greens are the faction that support
the claim of fagon the second targaryen
their rivals being the blacks who
support the claim of rhaenyra targaryen
both were named for the color of their
clothes worn during one tourney the
forced closeness of rhaenyras and delis
and children increased animosity between
the blacks and the greens
the royal children and grandchildren
became dragon riders and court visitors
observed the dragons of one faction
snapping and spitting flames at the
dragons of the other party
zerus dies in mid-season on the third
day of the third moon of 129 ac
during a nap in the red keep of king's
landing on his deathbed he refuses to
change the succession and decrease his
heir to be rhaenyra he is found dead by
a servant who first goes to alicent to
inform her of viserys's death which
proves to be a grave mistake as ellison
proclaims aegon the king over the
vicious of his heirs
at a time of her father's death rainer
is on dragonstone as is the place for
true air
the green sinking's landing ensure that
the news of iserius's death does not
reach rhaenyra until her own supporters
in the red keep are dead or imprisoned
and dagon the second's coronation had
already occurred
king viserys decorated rhaenyra to
succeed him but aegon the elder the
eldest son of his second wife alicent is
instead crowned aegon ii by sir christon
cole the lord commander of the
kingsguard on dragonstone rhaenyra
learns about the death of her father and
the betrayal of her siblings
rhaenyra in answer to aegon's betrayal
is crowned a queen at dragonstone and
swears revenge
this leads to a civil war between
rhaenyra and aegon the dance of the
dragons
a war of succession between aegon ii and
his half sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne the
devastating civil war that tore apart
the seven kingdoms
the war lasted for three years and by
the time it came to an end thousands
were dead nearly all of the targaryen
dragons had been killed as well as many
targaryens themselves it didn't start
outright with war using dragons and
armies but at first it was a war of
ravens
rhaenyra makes her own council at
dragonstone the black council
participants are amongst others her
uncle husband daemon her three eldest
sons she carries lucius and joffrey lord
corliss valerian and his wife princess
rhaenys during the council it's resolved
that while rhaenyra remains at
dragonstone to regain her health prince
daemon and characters will travel to the
riverlands to make harrenhal their base
and railing point for those loyal to
rhaenyra
house valerian will close off the gullet
blocking all shipping from blackwater
bay
princess rhaenys is convinced that
storm's end will declare for rhaenyra
since lord bormund baratheon the
deceased father of lord boros and
rhaenys's uncle had always been a
supporter of rhaenys prince daemon is
also convinced that lady jane eyring the
maiden of the vale will bring her
support to their side although they
believe the north to be too remote to
play an important part in the war
messages are to be sent to those lords
nevertheless
rhaenyra's sons themselves depart to
rally the lords to their side with the
eldest jacares visiting the aryans of
the erie the manderlists of white
harbour and the starks of winterfell
rhaenyra's second son lucerus travels to
storm's end
prince daemon leads the first attack of
the war on harehole which is conquered
without bloodshed the castle answer
simon strong yields when he sees
daemon's dragon
this conquest leads to victories of the
blacks at the burning mill and
stonehedge and allow the river lords
such as house blackwood to gather at
harrenhal
in the meantime jacarius gains lady iran
and the lords manderly borle and
sunderland and craig and stark to
rhaenyra's cause with kragen allying
through the pact of ice and fire
towards the end of season 1 the first
battle between targaryens and their
dragons will occur which will set the
dark tone for the rest of the war filled
with blood fire revenge and grief the
dance over shipbreaker bay
losers flies to storm's end arriving
before a gathering storm he finds prince
aymond one eye and his dragon vegard
already present was there on his brother
king aegon's behalf to win the baratheon
lord to his side
prince eamon and lustris had bad blood
even prior to this as when they were
younger lucerius took out a man's eye
with a dagger in a fight
amen tries to provoke loose race into a
fight insulting him calling him a strong
bastard but loser is thorn not to fight
or refuses him
he delivers his message to lord boris
baratheon but is refused and told to
leave
lord baratheon prevents aemond from
attacking his cousin in the castle but
allows for the prince to follow him
mounted on his dragon aemon catches up
with loose rays during a raging storm
the fight between the two dragons does
not last long
vagar being five times bigger has the
advantage and airax falls broken rhinera
collapses when learning of luceri's
death prince daemon at carrick hall
sends a raven to his wife promising that
her son's death would be avenged
using one of his friends from king's
landing his former lover and current
mistress of whispers miseria who is
played by an actress sonoya mizuno
daemon enlists the help of a former
sergeant in the city watch known now
only as blood and the red catcher from
the red keep now known only as cheese
the two sneak into the red keep using
secret tunnels and hidden doors which
brings them into the tower of the hand
their queen ellis scent is bound and
gagged and her bed made strangled when
queen halina king aegon's sister wife
and their three children appear blood
and cheese close the doors and tell
haley not to choose which of her sons
will die
haley now reluctantly chooses mailer
because he's younger but blood does the
opposite
and kills the older prince instead
the two flee with the prince's head
leaving the others unharmed and daemon
proves his word to rhaenyra and they hit
back at king aegon a son for a son
this is the season 1 finale and it sets
the tone for the upcoming seasons filled
with fire and blood revenge and grief
deaths of targaryens their dragons and
their armies
raman javadi the composer of game of
thrones epic music is back to compose
for all these epic scenes in house of
the dragon if you like epic drama series
filled not only with epic battles
between armies and dragons but also
filled with court politics betrayals and
everything that made you fall in love
with the world of westeros in the first
place
then you're going to love this game of
thrones prequel house of the dragon
begins filming in about 1 month and will
premiere in 2022 on hbo thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
video please give it a big thumbs up and
i hope to see you in the next one peace